en 1977 des femmes revendiquent le droit
à la contraception et le pouvoir de
décider pour elles-mêmes
c'est l'année où l'onu décrète que le 8
mars sera la journée internationale des
femmes
mais bien avant des organisations se
sont donné une journée annuelle pour
manifester et revendiquer le droit de
vote où le droit au travail dans des
conditions acceptables
elle était littéralement chaîne et à la
machine à coudre donc son on part de là
on peut dire que des progrès comme la
meinau qui ont été faits de façon très
inégale
les femmes ont encore des gains
importants à faire selon le bilan que
dresse cette professeur de l'uqam la
sécurité qui est évidemment un enjeu as
important violences faites aux femmes
oui encore des problèmes quand même où
on se classe assez milieu de peloton le
temps on n'est pas des premiers de
classe on se compare à l'ontario sens
comparé à la colombie-britannique depuis
deux ans cette préoccupation a connu un
nouveau 6
une question lancinante et qui est gardé
dans l'art j'ai gardé très vivant par la
ténacité du mouvement mi tour moi je le
vois dans mon mieux travail des gars qui
se sont posés la question agite ce fait
quelque chose puis je me suis même pas
rendu compte au niveau de l'icdi
salariale on sait que majoritairement
c'est les femmes l'eau qui sont dans les
emplois les plus précaires prenons
énormément de chemin à faire dans le
réseau de la santé pour nos
professionnels surtout dans le domaine
privé dans les domaines non syndiqués on
voit que les écarts salariaux encore
important et qui ne se justifie d'aucune
façon que autre marque par la
discrimination meilleure reconnaissance
des emplois féminins il serait temps de
payer les infirmières aux salaires
qu'elles méritent vraiment leur hymne à
130 et beaux jours devant lui
ce qui est malheureusement pas une bonne
nouvelle pour les femmes mais bon nous
on va mener le combat qui va falloir le
faire
l'écart salarial entre les hommes et les
femmes est de 13 pour cent au québec ici
anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal